i drew this house on a piece of paper
uh 18 or 19 years ago
we lived in it for almost 16 years
and it burned on august 9th into the
ground it burned
for a long time actually
[Music]
so when
our house caught fire
we had to leave immediately with nothing
with the clothes on our back and i was
in flip-flops and john was in kind of
old beat up boat shoes
and
we
ran across the street with our brand new
adopted
dog
and we watched the house burn until
about 3 a.m we cried like much later
when i realized i lost all my mom's
letters
all the letters my mom had written me
throughout my life the house was 100
percent lost
it took rachel and her husband john over
a year to rebuild their home in upstate
new york after a devastating fire broke
out in the chimney and destroyed
everything i thought the one thing that
had been saved for me was the pizza oven
but
a week later
the last
bean work fell and cracked it in half so
i lost the pizza oven too
what are some things that you did change
this time around nothing i tried to make
it exactly the same in fact i'm really
upset i lost my linen closet we forgot
to put it back in we changed the
material of the roof to tin
so that we are not going to be the three
little pigs twice
rachel invited us in for an exclusive
first look at her home all decked out
for christmas most of the furniture is a
recreation of pieces lost in the fire
but the one mistake rachel says she made
picking out this stuff it took me
six or seven days to figure out how to
turn the stove on and i'm not joking it
has a what looks like a touch pad but
it's not a touch pad and you have to use
two different dials it's a very
difficult stove and it makes a lot of
weird noises i mean i bought the stove
because it was pretty
but i should have read the fine print
i love this rachel this is fantastic
that's my old coffee table that they
made from
just the general pictures that i had
right
for now rachel's still shooting the
rachel ray show partly from home and
partly in studio and she's got a new
book out this must be the place
featuring recipes and stories from her
life over the last year the book is
really about gratitude it's not a total
bummer it's about connecting with people
because everyone on the planet went
through the same thing at the same time
everyone had to pivot everyone suffered
some sort of loss i did feel like we
lost our privacy first then we lost our
dog then we lost our home
but in the end what we learned is that
gave us more security than we had ever
had and sharing with people
in the most transparent way
that's bonded us
with our our viewers and our friends and
our family in a different way
than it ever had before
[Music]
you